few days out in the wasteland and it's  time to kick back at home my home made  my way one thing about humans we keep  trying to destroy this planet and the  planet just won't let us life always  finds a way time to use this century's  advanced technology to my own advantage  to help with all this radiation nothing  says home like corrugated metal and  loose live wires hey it's comfortable  never said it was safe look I don't  always play by the rules but mostly  because out here in the Commonwealth  there are no rules in this harsh new  world you may not be able to stop the  nightmares but you can control them the  custom cried said I'd blood wish that I  was dead what so maybe I get lonely  sometimes capturing them is fun but  letting them out hell yeah that's right  entertain me  sometimes feels like everything in the  Commonwealth wants to kill you are they  threats now decorations I never was the  type of want my name up in lights  sometimes you just need to advertise